chief washington correspondent mike
emanuel tells us how that might work
for migrants entering the country
illegally there's an effort to provide
them with a lawyer
on the taxpayer dime
president biden's 2022 budget requests
15 million dollars
to allow certain illegal immigrants to
hire private lawyers for their asylum
cases
another 23 million dollars would cover
legal orientation programs
administered by the justice department
it is not the time
to come and try to go through a regular
migration we want to have
an effective process where you can apply
for asylum
where you can apply for legal status fox
news has learned the justice department
has already awarded nearly 80 million
dollars in government contracts
to the vera institute for legal services
at the border
much of the money focused on helping
unaccompanied minors
it would be a fiscal bottomless pit
the conservative heritage foundation has
studied this issue
and notes this would give illegal
immigrants a right
american citizens do not have if you
think about the
costs and attorneys fees and the hours
spent
in consultation and preparation and
court time
it's thousands of dollars just for a
deportation defense
current law allows migrants to receive
representation from attorneys
from the many pro bono groups that offer
legal assistance
or out of their own pockets many of
these private groups say
some government funding is necessary and
welcome
part of the pitch is this is designed to
help migrant women and children and
while the current proposed spending is
small
in government terms critics know once
the government starts providing that
benefit it is virtually impossible to
take it away
experts say this is a fight that would
seem likely heading for court
brett mike thank you hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else